Katrina: 这是谁啊
Katrina: Who's this?
Shure: 啊看我笑的多灿烂啊
Shure: Ah, look at how brightly I'm smiling.
Shure: 啊我又暗淡了
Shure: Ah, now I've dimmed again.
Shure: 老板知道为什么我暗淡了吗
Shure: Boss, do you know why I'm feeling down?
Jack: 因为没给钱是吧
Jack: Because you didn't get paid, right?
Shure: 因为我想涨工资
Shure: Because I want a raise.
Jack: 啊
Jack: Ah.
Shure: 可以了可以了可以了
Shure: It's okay, it's okay, it's okay.
Shure: 哈哈哈
Shure: Hahaha.
Jake:准时
Jake: On time.
Shure: 懂懂
Shure: Got it.
Shure: 这叫什么
Shure: What do you call this?
Shure: 音乐脱口秀
Shure: Music talk show.
Shure: 懂了吧
Shure: Got it?
Jake: 可以
Jake: Yes.
Alice:你这状态持续多久了
Alice: How long have you been like this?
Jack: 这是有有病
Jack: This is a problem.
Jack: 有病得治
Jack: Problems need to be fixed.
Katrina: 你弹的够悲伤的
Katrina: Your playing is sad enough.
Nicous: 妈的 跟着修硕这节奏
Nicous: Damn, following Shure's rhythm.
Tasha:哈哈
Tasha: Haha.
Shure: 怎么我的诗朗诵不好吗
Shure: Is my poetry recital not good?
Katrina: 特别好都想哭了
Katrina: It's so good, it makes me want to cry.
Jack: 太好了
Jack: It's fantastic.
男嘉宾:关了
Male Guest: Turn it off.
Shure: 我都不知道难忘今宵的歌词是啥
Shure: I don't even know the lyrics to "Unforgettable Night."
Jake:就就这个
Jake: Just this.
Shure: 难忘今宵
Shure: Unforgettable night.
Shure: 我们大家一起大合唱
Shure: Let's all sing together.
刘婷:这是你们的固定节目吗
Liu Ting: Is this a regular part of your show?
Jack: 我们来点年头小点的吧
Jack: Let's do something more recent.
Alice:哈哈是吧
Alice: Haha, right?
Shure: 年头小点的歌
Shure: A more recent song.
Shure: 怎么你你哈哈哈
Shure: Why are you, you, haha.
Jack: 哎这个可以可以
Jack: Oh, this is good, good.
Alice:我俩坐那吧
Alice: Let's sit over there.
Jake:难忘哈哈哈
Jake: Unforgettable, haha.
Alice:你把凳子搬过来呗
Alice: Move the chair over here.
Katrina: 他改精神攻击了
Katrina: He's turned to mental attacks now.
Jack: 你就会这一句是吧
Jack: You only know this one line, right?
Shure: 对
Shure: Yes.
Jake:不行了不行
Jake: It's not working, no.
Jake:你还要加工资
Jake: You still want a raise.
Shure: 什么
Shure: What?
Jake:你还要加工资
Jake: You still want a raise?
Shure: 对啊
Shure: Yeah.
Jack: 这应该 是后经也损人位是吧
Jack: This should be the post-effects, right?
Shure: 大家有有什么想听的歌吗
Shure: Does anyone have a song they want to hear?
Shure: XBZ都会弹
Shure: XBZ can play anything.
Nicous: 我会库吗
Nicous: Can I play?
Nicous: 哎呀这终于恢复正常了
Nicous: Ah, finally back to normal.
Nicous: 来来来找个什么歌唱什么
Nicous: Come on, let's find a song to sing.
Shure: 唱什么
Shure: What to sing?
Shure: 你刚才说什么
Shure: What did you just say?
Shure: 不会
Shure: No way.
Jack: 看起来可以唱
Jack: Looks like you can sing.
女嘉宾:真的很会唱啊
Female Guest: Really good at singing!
Jack: 能唱就唱
Jack: If you can sing, then sing.
Shure: 给大家表演一个
Shure: I'll perform for everyone.
Shure: 每次都会在酒后给大家表演的
Shure: I always perform after drinking.
Shure: 叫什么来着哈哈
Shure: What's it called again, haha?
Shure: 对
Shure: Right.
Shure: 来吧
Shure: Let's go.
Alice:本人不伤心
Alice: I’m not sad.
Shure: 来吧
Shure: Come on.
Alice:试这个点心
Alice: Try this snack.
Shure: 就四个和弦
Shure: Just four chords.
Shure: 你往低了点弹不就得了吗
Shure: Play it a bit lower, would you?
Shure: 哎呀我都能
Shure: Oh, I can do it.
Shure: 弹到哪了
Shure: Where did you play up to?
Shure: 就1645四个和弦
Shure: Just 1645, four chords.
Shure: 我我我我我怎么怎么起的啊
Shure: How did I start it again?
Shure: 哎怎么怎么卧槽
Shure: Oh, how, what the heck?
Jack: 我又寡言掉了你懂个叫我行不
Jack: I went silent again, could you call me?
Shure: 我我我我最啊我最爱
Shure: I, I, I, I love, I love...
Shure: 卧哎卧槽
Shure: Oh, what the heck.
Shure: 哈哈哈等一下
Shure: Hahaha, wait a minute.
Alice:气急败坏
Alice: So frustrated!
Shure: 啊啊啊找到了
Shure: Ah, found it!
Shure: 谢谢大家谢谢大家
Shure: Thank you, everyone. Thank you!
Alice:我给你拿杯子
Alice: I'll get you a cup.
Shure: 好了我们的egoKTV
Shure: Alright, our egoKTV.
Nicous: 下一首
Nicous: Next song.
Jake: 下一首
Jake: Next song.
Shure: 别下一首了哈哈哈
Shure: No more songs, haha.
Shure: 一会老底都揭没了怎么办
Shure: What if all our secrets get revealed?
Jack: 下一首
Jack: Next song.
Shure: 哎大家大家
Shure: Hey everyone, everyone.
Alice:露西
Alice: Lucia.
Shure: 还会唱什么
Shure: What else can you sing?
Shure: 还听过什么
Shure: What else have you heard?
Shure: 就是能大家一起调动氛围一起唱的
Shure: Something that can get everyone involved and singing together.
Alice:想你了
Alice: Missing you.
Shure: 想想谁了
Shure: Who are you missing?
Alice:哦不不不
Alice: Oh no, no, no.
Shure: 想谁了哈哈哈
Shure: Who are you missing, haha.
Shure: 哈哈哈哈
Shure: Hahaha.
Lucia:人家想我了哈哈
Lucia: Someone's missing me, haha.
Shure: 哎呀想想想想
Shure: Oh, thinking, thinking, thinking.
Shure: 别普通朋友了哈哈
Shure: No more being just friends, haha.
Shure: 老老在这唱这多晦气是吧哈哈
Shure: Singing sad songs here is so unlucky, right? Haha.
Shure: 什么东西
Shure: What is this?
Shure: 你这什么风格
Shure: What's your style?
Jack: 你今天弹这个
Jack: You're playing this today.
Jack: 应该有很多什么情歌之类的
Jack: There should be a lot of love songs or something.
Jack: 就流沙嘛
Jack: Like quicksand.
Jack: 爱情好像流沙
Jack: Love is like quicksand.
Jack: 不复挣扎嘛
Jack: Struggling in vain.
Lucia:出现
Lucia: Appear.
Shure: 我这就
Shure: I'm just...
Lucia:你今天晚上住这边吗
Lucia: Are you staying here tonight?
Shure: 主要已经脱离了那个唱苦情歌的阶段
Shure: Mainly, I've moved past the stage of singing sad love songs.
Alice:嗯
Alice: Hmm.
男嘉宾:有了对像了是吧
Male Guest: You have a partner now, right?
Shure: 对
Shure: Right.
Katrina: 那你唱那个
Katrina: Then you should sing that one.
Jack: 那那那来点甜甜的吧
Jack: Then let's hear something sweet.
Katrina: 你唱那个
Katrina: You should sing that one.
Katrina: 恋爱ING吧反正你也是恋爱ING
Katrina: Love ING, since you're in love anyway.
Shure: 恋爱ING的词是什么来着
Shure: What's the lyrics to Love ING again?
Shure: 那那有点唱不上去
Shure: That one's a bit hard to sing.
男嘉宾:情非得已
Male Guest: Unintentionally in love.
Alice:咋啦
Alice: What's up?
刘婷:快跟人亲热亲热快点
Liu Ting: Hurry up and get cozy with them, quick!
Katrina: 情非得已也行
Katrina: Even if it's forced, it's fine.
男嘉宾:有何不可
Male Guest: Why not?
Katrina: 唱素颜吧
Katrina: Sing "Bare-faced"!
Alice:我鞋呢
Alice: Where are my shoes?
Katrina: 对着你女朋友唱素颜
Katrina: Sing "Bare-faced" to your girlfriend.
Jake:哎唱素颜了
Jake: Hey, sing "Bare-faced".
Alice:我这人不爱穿鞋有什么毛病
Alice: I don't like wearing shoes, what's wrong with that?
Katrina: 你女朋友给你唱那个
Katrina: Your girlfriend is singing that to you.
Katrina: 她唱女生不
Katrina: Is she singing the girl's part?
男嘉宾:来点那什么小小那个
Male Guest: Sing a bit of that small part.
Alice:我又不脚臭
Alice: I don't have smelly feet.
Shure: 来嘛
Shure: Come on!
Katrina: 素颜嘛
Katrina: "Bare-faced"!
Shure: 唱一个素颜来了
Shure: Sing "Bare-faced".
Shure: 素颜来了
Shure: "Bare-faced".
Katrina: 来嘛
Katrina: Come on!
Shure的女友:等会我再喝口
Shure's GF: Wait, let me have another drink.
Alice:我去给他拿杯子
Alice: I'll go get him a cup.
Shure: 行
Shure: Okay.
Jack: 素颜 素颜
Jack: "Bare-faced", "Bare-faced".
Shure: 来给我给我也整一杯
Shure: Get me a cup too.
Alice:哎哟
Alice: Oops.
Shure的女友:还有杯子吗
Shure's GF: Are there any cups left?
Alice:来我给你洗一个
Alice: Let me wash one for you.
Alice:哎没了我靠
Alice: Oh no, we're out of them.
刘婷:用碗也行
Liu Ting: A bowl works too.
Alice:好那我就碗了啊
Alice: Alright, I'll use a bowl then.
Shure的女友:这没杯子了吗
Shure's GF: Are there really no cups?
Alice:这没了
Alice: We're out.
Shure: 你能可以只弹左手
Shure: Can you play with just your left hand?
Shure: 刘帅要不你替我弹
Shure: Choiszt, can you play for me?
Choiszt: 我没听过你弹这个
Choiszt: I've never heard you play this.
Shure: 你弹弹就行
Shure: Just play it.
Katrina: 你没听过这歌
Katrina: Haven't you heard this song?
Shure: 哎OK OK
Shure: Hey, OK OK.
男嘉宾:喂 喂
Male Guest: Hello, hello.
Alice:给
Alice: Here.
Alice:擦过了哈哈哈
Alice: Wiped clean, haha.
Alice:不用这么客气
Alice: No need to be so polite.
Shure: 怎么还整俩碗呢
Shure: Why are there two bowls?
Shure: 结拜了是吗
Shure: Are you pledging brotherhood or something?
Katrina: 哎这是啥意思
Katrina: Hey, what does this mean?
Alice:让我过去
Alice: Let me through.
Shure: 我要那 就要 还没
Shure: I want that one, it's not ready yet.
Alice:你要吗露西哦你不能喝哦
Alice: Do you want it, Lucia? Oh, you can't drink it.
Lucia:我不喝
Lucia: I don't drink.
Alice:刘婷你喝不喝
Alice: Liu Ting, do you drink?
Alice:你别喝了
Alice: Don't drink it.
Alice:小孩不让喝酒
Alice: Kids can't drink alcohol.
Lucia:这不是饮料这是水
Lucia: This isn't a drink, it's water.
Shure: 可以可以哇哈哈哈
Shure: Okay, okay, wahahaha.
男嘉宾:用碗
Male Guest: Use the bowl.
Shure: 你说啥
Shure: What did you say?
Alice:没杯子
Alice: No cups.
Lucia:微醺
Lucia: A little tipsy.
Shure: 纯饮一碗是吧
Shure: Drinking a whole bowl, right?
Katrina: 农夫山泉微醺水
Katrina: Nongfu Spring tipsy water.
Jack: 可以可以
Jack: Okay, okay.
Shure: 随便随便
Shure: Whatever, whatever.
Katrina: 行你两个小时确实有点
Katrina: Alright, two hours is indeed a bit...
Alice:你喝吗 哦你不喝
Alice: Do you drink? Oh, you don't.
Alice:我今晚怎么回事
Alice: What's going on with me tonight?
Lucia:一顿乱回
Lucia: Just rambling.
Jack: 可以啊 厉害呀
Jack: Sure, impressive.
Jake:手挺狠啊
Jake: Pretty tough, huh?
Jack: 要喝好啊
Jack: Want to drink, huh?
Alice:紫棠你要吗
Alice: Zitang, do you want it?
Katrina: 拜拜拜拜
Katrina: Bye, bye.
Alice:我下去给你找个杯子啥的
Alice: I'll go downstairs and find you a cup or something.
Shure: 哎呀不好
Shure: Oh no, not good.
Alice:你不要吗
Alice: You don't want it?
Katrina: 那我把他送到门口吧走吧
Katrina: Then I'll see him to the door, let's go.
Alice:你要吗你要吗
Alice: Do you want it? Do you want it?
Alice:我给你找个容器
Alice: I'll find you a container.
Jack: 啥也不可以
Jack: Nothing is allowed.
Alice:我给你拿个
Alice: I'll get you a...
Alice:拿个容器
Alice: Get you a container.
Alice:虽然我自己也不在 我来都来了
Alice: Although I'm not here myself, I've already come.
Jake:哎呀 我真傻
Jake: Oh man, I'm so dumb.
Shure: 哎哟 嗨 嗨 嗨 嗨 嗨
Shure: Oh hey hey hey hey hey
Shure: 还有还有还有还有还有还有还有还有
Shure: There's more, more, more, more, more, more, more
Jake: 真傻了这个哈哈哈
Jake: This is so silly, hahaha
Jake:你也正好壮点胆
Jake: You might as well get some courage
Jake:对 报应
Jake: Yeah, karma
Shure: 你你你先溜了吧
Shure: You, you, you should sneak away first
Shure: 你先找一会去吧你
Shure: You go find something for a while
Lucia:我觉得还不错
Lucia: I think it's not bad
Jake:哎人呢
Jake: Hey, where is everyone?
Lucia:来点吗
Lucia: Want some?
Lucia:不能用一次性的
Lucia: Can't use disposables
Lucia:今天是世界地球日
Lucia: Today is Earth Day
Shure: 对
Shure: Right
Jake:哦好这就是我们5天的排练结果
Jake: Oh okay, this is the result of our 5 days of rehearsal
Shure: 我给你给你
Shure: I'll give it to you, to you
Shure: 声音开小点好不好哦
Shure: Turn the volume down a bit, okay?
Jake:十分默契
Jake: Very in sync
Shure: 人没上来
Shure: The person didn't come up
Lucia:基本上只能靠默契
Lucia: Basically, we can only rely on being in sync
Jake:对
Jake: Yes
Shure: 没有没有
Shure: No, no
Shure: 一般一般一般
Shure: Just average, average
Jake:好好
Jake: Okay, okay
Shure: 这个这个
Shure: This, this
Jake:你呀 你
Jake: You, you
Jake:这个数据集是不是全球独一份 老板
Jake: Is this dataset unique in the world, boss?
Jake:确实
Jake: Indeed
Shure: 就我们这数据集的价值我跟你讲
Shure: Just the value of our dataset, let me tell you
Shure: 无可估量
Shure: Is immeasurable
Shure: 我开始学老板反向画饼哈哈哈
Shure: I'm starting to learn from the boss how to reverse-pitch, hahaha
Jake:太 确实
Jake: Really, indeed
Shure: 来吧你给我倒回去吧
Shure: Come on, rewind it for me
Shure: 放这吧放这吧
Shure: Put it here, put it here
Shure: 我倒回去
Shure: I'll rewind it
Alice:给你拿巧克力
Alice: Got you some chocolate
Lucia:谢谢
Lucia: Thanks
Jake:就朝着弱智吧那路去了
Jake: Heading down the path of an idiot
Alice:恩将仇报是吧
Alice: Returning good for evil, huh?
Shure: 我们我们
Shure: We, we
Shure: 这个是人类
Shure: This is humanity
Shure: 其实是一些正常的活动
Shure: Actually, it's just some normal activities.
Jake:哎正常活动
Jake: Yeah, normal activities.
Jake:都很正常
Jake: All very normal.
Shure: 不不不造作
Shure: No, no, not pretentious.
Shure: 不
Shure: No.
Jake:就 就你不喝酒就唱不上去
Jake: You just can't sing unless you drink.
Jake:这很的
Jake: It's really...
Shure: 对
Shure: Right.
Jake:对 这个就
Jake: Yeah, this is just...
Shure: AI根本想不到这点对吧
Shure: AI can't even think of this, right?
Shure: 能啊
Shure: It can, though.
Jack: 你错过了
Jack: You missed it.
Jake:再来一次
Jake: Let's do it again.
Jack: 精彩发言
Jack: Great speech.
男嘉宾:你说高不高呢
Male Guest: Do you think it's high or not?
Jack: 这样
Jack: Like this.
Jack: 这你 你先说
Jack: You go first.
Jack: 你说高不高吧
Jack: Do you think it's high or not?
Shure: 好
Shure: Okay.
Shure: 哎我靠
Shure: Oh, wow.
Shure: 来吧女嘉宾
Shure: Come on, lady guest.
Alice:吃提拉米苏不吃
Alice: Do you want some tiramisu?
Shure: 来吧
Shure: Come on.
Alice:我给你切一个吧
Alice: I'll cut you a piece.
男嘉宾:刚刚喝酒干嘛呢
Male Guest: What were you doing while drinking earlier?
Shure: 对啊
Shure: Yeah.
Alice:拿着啊
Alice: Hold this.
男嘉宾:你已经忘了喝酒干嘛了
Male Guest: You've already forgotten why you were drinking.
Jake:呵呵看来喝挺多
Jake: Haha, looks like you drank a lot.
男嘉宾:已经倒半天了
Male Guest: It's been pouring for ages.
Alice:这有水
Alice: There's water here.
男嘉宾:嗯
Male Guest: Hmm.
Alice:行
Alice: Okay.
Alice:别玩抽象
Alice: Don't mess with the abstract.
Shure: 词写上了
Shure: The lyrics are on.
Jake:有 有词有词
Jake: Yeah, got the lyrics.
Shure: 呃你稍微放大一点
Shure: Uh, zoom in a bit.
Jake:呃
Jake: Uh.
Shure: 刘帅好OK
Shure: Choiszt, okay.
Shure: 然后你来翻谱对OK
Shure: Then you can turn the pages, okay.
Jake:我 我来给你播
Shure: 这回能看清了吧
Shure: Can you see it clearly now?
Shure: 我
Shure: I...
男嘉宾:倒酒
Male Guest: Pour the wine.
Shure: 来吧来吧拿 过来
Shure: Come on, bring it over.
Alice:我给你拿个勺子类的东西
Alice: I'll get you something like a spoon.
Shure: 来吧准备
Shure: Come on, get ready.
Shure: 可以了
Shure: It's done.
Alice:你修修图啊稍等我
Alice: Are you editing the picture? Wait for me.
Shure:  一段就可以了
Shure: Just a segment is fine.
Jack: 你有没有拍下去呢
Jack: Did you get a shot?
男嘉宾:刚刚发生了什么
Male Guest: What just happened?
Jake:啊没看见
Jake: Ah, didn't see it.
Alice:什么什么什么
Alice: What, what, what?
Alice:波啦
Alice: Broadcast it.
Jake:OK OK没关系这边有个机会
Jake: OK, OK, no worries, there's another chance here.
Alice:哎呀
Alice: Oh no.
Katrina: 我今天晚上受不了了
Katrina: I can't take it anymore tonight.
Katrina: 哈哈哈哈
Katrina: Hahaha.
Katrina: 啊真难受
Katrina: Ah, it's really uncomfortable.
Katrina: 点一首唯一
Katrina: Play "The Only One."
Alice:在来一块
Alice: Play another one.
Shure: 来吧
Shure: Come on.
Nicous: 小黄 唱吧
Nicous: Nicous, sing it.
Katrina: E了
Katrina: E it.
Shure: 您来唱
Shure: You sing it.
Katrina: 真E了
Katrina: Really E it.
男嘉宾:咱心里
Male Guest: We...
男嘉宾:也是难以
Male Guest: Also difficult...
Tasha:也是男女
Tasha: Also men and women...
Shure: 我不会
Shure: I can't.
Shure的女友:那首我真不会
Nurse: I really can't sing that one.
Shure的女友:这首还唱过
Nurse: I've sung this one.
Shure的女友:那首真不会
Nurse: I really can't sing that one.
男嘉宾:OK
Male Guest: OK.
男嘉宾:告五人的是不是王力宏的
Male Guest: Is "告五人" Wang Leehom's?
Shure: 对 告5人的
Shure: Yes, it's by "告5人."
Shure: 告五人的
Shure: By "告五人."
Shure: 告5人的
Shure: By "告5人."
Shure: 告五人你弹的是王力宏的
Shure: You played Wang Leehom's version of "告五人."
Shure: 你谈的是王力宏的啊
Shure: Are you talking about Leehom Wang?
男嘉宾:这是告五人的吗
Male Guest: Is this by Accusefive?
Jack: 啊告五人
Jack: Ah, Accusefive.
Jack: 这这这跟那个有什么区别吗
Jack: What's the difference between this and that?
Nicous: 是两个两个
Nicous: They're two different ones.
Shure: 完全不一样的歌
Shure: Completely different songs.
Nicous: 完全不一样
Nicous: Totally different.
Shure: 两种不一样
Shure: Two different kinds.
Jack: 哦
Jack: Oh.
Shure: 来吧
Shure: Come on.
Katrina: 我真的能唱吗
Katrina: Can I really sing?
Shure: 你可以的
Shure: You can do it.
Katrina: 来
Katrina: Alright.
Shure: 你不行少和弦就行
Shure: If you can't, just use fewer chords.
Katrina: 你帮我合着点
Katrina: Help me harmonize a bit.
Shure: 我还帮你合着点
Shure: I'll help you harmonize a bit.
Katrina: 就大家帮我合着点
Katrina: Everyone help me harmonize a bit.
Katrina: 我一个人唱我的声音我会觉得很尴尬
Katrina: Singing alone makes me feel awkward.
Shure: 好
Shure: Okay.
Katrina: 我看从哪开始
Katrina: Let me see where to start.
Katrina: 我靠挺好我不知道从哪进
Katrina: Oh wow, I don't know where to begin.
Alice:吃提拉米苏吗我给你切一块
Alice: Want some tiramisu? I'll cut you a piece.
Katrina: 你能提示一下吗
Katrina: Can you give me a hint?
Lucia:我下午吃了
Lucia: I had some in the afternoon.
Alice:他说挺好吃的
Alice: He said it was pretty good.
Lucia:对我也觉得挺好吃的
Lucia: Yeah, I thought it was pretty good too.
Lucia:是吧
Lucia: Right?
Katrina: 我也觉得
Katrina: I think so too.
Alice:吃提拉米苏吗我给你切一块
Alice: Want some tiramisu? I'll cut you a piece.
Shure: 哎我直接弹了得了
Shure: Hey, I'll just play it.
Shure: 来吧来吧
Shure: Come on, come on.
Shure的女友:我吃过了
Shure: I've already eaten.
Alice:你要吗
Alice: Do you want some?
Lucia:我们俩一起吃的
Lucia: We ate it together.
Shure: 你这怎么D调你知道吗
Shure: Do you know how to play in D key?
Alice:你要吗给你切一下
Alice: Do you want some? I'll cut you a piece.
男嘉宾:我从来不用这些
Male Guest: I never use these.
Alice:我得给你找个容器
Alice: I'll find a container for you.
Shure: 我草
Shure: Damn.
Shure: 你给我移个调我就可以可以
Shure: Move it to another key for me, then I can do it.
Alice:给你用这个吧
Alice: Use this for you
Katrina: 这是在干什么呢
Katrina: What are you doing?
Alice:你在乱叫
Alice: You're yelling
Alice:妈我杀了你
Alice: Mom, I'll kill you
Shure: 等一下啊
Shure: Wait a second
Shure: 我稍等我稍微移个调就可以
Shure: Hold on, I'll adjust the pitch a bit
Shure: 你怎么移调啊
Shure: How do you adjust the pitch?
男嘉宾:这歌你没听过吗
Male Guest: Haven't you heard this song?
Shure: 哎
Shure: Huh?
Katrina: 没听过吗
Katrina: Haven't heard it?
Nicous: 哦这这这这这个
Nicous: Oh this this this this
Jake:这两天来少了
Jake: There have been fewer visitors these days
男嘉宾:不会每天都唱吧
Male Guest: You don't sing every day, right?
Katrina: 每天都唱这首歌一到晚上
Katrina: Sing this song every night
Jake:每天都唱
Jake: Sing every day
Shure: 要不这个我帮你弹
Shure: How about I play for you?
男嘉宾:啊
Male Guest: Huh?
Jack: 哦
Jack: Oh
Shure: 你这调对吗你想想
Shure: Is your pitch right? Think about it
Alice:露西亚让我过一下下
Alice: Lucia, let me pass for a moment
Lucia:啊好的
Lucia: Ah, okay
Alice:哎我看有点
Alice: Hey, I see a bit of
Lucia:这个呃是不是还要在
Lucia: This, uh, do we need to
Alice:噢噢谢谢
Alice: Oh oh thanks
Lucia:没事
Lucia: No problem
Lucia:嗯
Lucia: Hmm
Jake:谢彬竹没搞定
Jake: Xie Binzhu didn't manage it
Shure: 你就全程在这翻手机
Shure: You're just scrolling on your phone the whole time
Shure: 你在你在后面有什么用
Shure: What's the use of you being in the back?
Shure: 四级
Shure: Level 4
Shure: 然后你往上移半个调不就得了吗
Shure: Then just move up half a pitch, won't you?
Shure: 笨死了可
Shure: So stupid
Shure: 哎
Shure: Hey
Katrina: 从头吗
Katrina: From the beginning?
Jack: 从头吧
Jack: From the start
Shure: OK能不能找到了哥
Shure: OK, can you find it now?
Shure: 这次
Shure: This time
Shure: 这这次
Shure: 那我就给你声开大点了啊
Shure: I'll turn up the volume for you then
Alice:要哪个
Alice: Which one do you want?
Shure: 真没有问题了
Shure: There's really no problem.
Shure: 哈哈哈哎
Shure: Hahaha hey
Nicous: 准备
Nicous: Ready
Jake:你又行了了是吧
Jake: You're good to go again, huh?
Shure: 他又行了
Shure: He's good to go again.
Alice:行
Alice: Okay
Shure: 能不能找到他哥
Shure: Can we find his brother?
Katrina: 嗯
Katrina: Hmm
Shure: 那刚才不是完事了吗
Shure: Wasn't it all done just now?
Alice:能给我发个消息吗找不着你了
Alice: Can you send me a message? I can't find you.
Shure: 好终于对上了
Shure: Okay, finally matched up.
Alice:太卡了
Alice: It's too laggy.
Shure: 你在你在后面有什么用
Shure: What's the use of you being at the back?
Katrina: 来
Katrina: Here
Alice:搜不到
Alice: Can't find it.
Jake:你真的懂
Jake: You really get it.
Jake:呀
Jake: Ah
Katrina: OK哦
Katrina: OK
Katrina: 换下一首
Katrina: Next song
Shure: 还有要表演的同学
Shure: Any other students want to perform?
男嘉宾:靖康
Male Guest: Jingkang
Shure: 靖康你会唱什么
Shure: Jingkang, what can you sing?
Katrina: 唱一首
Katrina: Sing a song.
Shure: 这老板得唱一首吧
Shure: The boss should sing a song, right?
Shure: 唱什么老板啊
Shure: What will the boss sing?
Jake:啊
Jake: Ah
男嘉宾:你会唱什么
Male Guest: What can you sing?
Katrina: 爱拼才会赢
Katrina: "Love to Win"
Jake:行来
Jake: Okay, let's go.
Shure: 真的吗
Shure: Really?
Shure: 老板真会唱吗
Shure: Can the boss really sing?
Jake:不会
Jake: No
Shure: 老板会会
Shure: The boss can, can.
Shure: 会唱点什么吗
Shure: Can he sing anything?
Alice:yes OK
Alice: Yes, OK.
女嘉宾:are you OK
Female Guest: Are you OK?
Jake:are you OK
Jake: Are you OK?
Alice:他的手机铃声
Alice: It's his ringtone.
Jake:are you OK这个倒是可以
Jake: "Are you OK" is fine.
Shure: 哎呦
Shure: Oh dear.
Lucia:婧康的手机铃声
Lucia: Jinkang's phone ringtone
Alice:are you OK
Alice: are you OK
Jake:are you OK
Alice:hello
Alice: hello
Shure: 那我
Shure: So I...
Shure: 这怎么办呢
Shure: What should I do now?
Shure: 这这大家以后你看
Shure: Look, everyone, in the future...
Shure: 这就是一个情商小课堂
Shure: This is a little emotional intelligence lesson
男嘉宾:富士山下
Male guest: Under Mount Fuji
男嘉宾:哦
Male guest: Oh
Jack: 可以可以
Jack: It's okay, it's okay
Alice:我现在就去山东进修
Alice: I'm going to Shandong for further studies now
Shure: 可以
Alice:呃山东
Alice: Uh, Shandong
Alice:呃哈哈哈哈
Alice: Uh, hahaha
Alice:情商小课堂
Alice: Emotional intelligence lesson
Shure: are you OK哈喽
Shure: are you OK, hello
Lucia:我靠
Lucia: Oh my god
Shure: 老板来
Shure: Boss, come here
Shure: 我觉得这样也可以
Shure: I think this is fine too
Shure: 咱们也不尴尬
Shure: We're not awkward
Jake:用不着用不着
Jake: No need, no need
Jake:用不着
Jake: No need
Jake:用不着用不着
Jake: No need, no need
Shure: 要成功哈哈哈
Shure: Must succeed, hahaha
Jake:先打
Jake: Hit first
Lucia:不是谁是老板啊
Lucia: Who's the boss here?
Shure: 老板老板
Shure: Boss, boss
Jake:用不着
Jake: No need
Jake:用不着用不着
Jake: No need, no need
Jake:呃算了
Jake: Uh, forget it
Jake:哈哈挺会
Jake: Haha, quite smart
Katrina: 这弹啥了
Katrina: What did they play?
Shure: 他把老板的歌词给弹了
Shure: He played the boss's lyrics
Shure: 这种一般都怎么处理呢
Shure: How do they usually handle this?
Alice:送去山东
Alice: Send to Shandong
Jack: 不趁着人多的时候说话知道不
Jack: Don't talk when there are too many people, got it?
Shure: 我感觉这样
Shure: I feel like this
Shure: 明天他左脚就可能踏进公司了吧
Shure: Tomorrow, he might step into the company with his left foot
Shure: 呃
Shure: Uh
Katrina: 那个唱富士山下
Katrina: Sing that song "Under the Mount Fuji"
Shure: 所以所以XBZ
Shure: So, so, XBZ
Jack: 可以
Jack: Sure
Shure: 你你在这里的
Shure: You, you're here
Katrina: 起一个什么作用呢
Katrina: What's your role here?
Shure: 气氛组
Shure: Atmosphere team
Katrina: 起一个logo作用哈哈哈
Katrina: Like a logo, haha
Shure: logo怎么这牌子
Shure: Logo? How's that a brand?
Shure: 打钱了是吗
Shure: Paid already?
Katrina: 唱点经典的
Katrina: Sing some classics
Katrina: 大家都会的
Katrina: Ones everyone knows
Shure: 来吧
Shure: Let's go
Katrina: 周杰伦陈奕迅
Katrina: Jay Chou, Eason Chan
Shure: 嗯
Shure: Hmm
Jack: 可不可以又弹又跳一条龙
Jack: How about singing and dancing all together?
男嘉宾:这有点难
Male Guest: That's a bit hard
Shure: 你好
Shure: Hello
Shure: 没事看看你
Shure: No worries, just checking you out
Shure: 没事 不用不用
Shure: No worries, no need
Katrina: 这个词有点难看到
Katrina: This line is hard to see
Shure: 对你这上不了桌回家的时候
Shure: Right, this won't be on the table when you go home
Shure: 现在先坐小孩的时候历练2年
Shure: Now, sit as a kid first, get some experience for two years
Shure: 哼 什么好的好的
Shure: Huh, alright, alright
Alice:好吗
Alice: Okay?
Alice:好的
Alice: Okay
Katrina: 好吧好的
Katrina: Alright, okay
Alice:好的
Alice: Okay
Alice:大兵打人装修吗
Alice: Is the soldier hitting people or renovating?
男嘉宾:来一个来一个来一个
Male Guest: Come on, come on, come on
Alice:再来一块吗还吃吗
Alice: Another piece? Still eating?
Jack: 给你拿麦  我给你拿麦
Jack: I'll hold the mic for you
Shure: 这太浓了
Shure: This is too thick
Jack: 我负责给你拿麦
Jack: I'll be responsible for holding the mic
Shure: 就跟我
Shure: Just like me
Shure: 要不给我就稍微倒一点
Shure: If not, just pour me a little bit
Alice:有但是太杂了这根本就没有一个
Alice: Yes, but it's too mixed, there's no one
Shure: 陈奕迅啊这是
Shure: Eason Chan, this is
Shure: 兑一起然后再分一半
Shure: Mix together and then split in half
Shure: 我给他录一个
Shure: I'll record one for him.
Lucia:哇好厉害
Lucia: Wow, that's amazing.
Shure: 啊他那天说的
Shure: Oh, he said that the other day.
Shure: 哇谢彬竹
Shure: Wow, thanks Bin Zhu.
Shure: 终于默契了一次
Shure: Finally, we synced up.
Shure: 我懂了问题出在我身上
Shure: I get it, the problem was with me.
Shure: 不是不是你身上
Shure: No, no, it's not you.
Shure: 懂了懂了
Shure: Got it, got it.
Shure: 跟跟跟那个帅师傅比较
Shure: It's that I'm more in sync with Master Shuai.
Shure: 比较投缘是吧
Shure: We get along better, right?
Nicous: 下一个
Nicous: Next one.
Shure: 下一个
Shure: Next one.
Jake:哎别你别你别
Jake: Hey, no, don't.
Shure: 靠 好
Shure: Damn, okay.
Nicous: 你来一个
Nicous: You do one.
Jake:对你来一个
Jake: Yeah, you do one.
男嘉宾:不用啦
Male Guest: No need.
Shure: 我们有全民K歌
Shure: We've got Karaoke for Everyone.
Katrina: 实在不行普通朋友
Katrina: If it doesn't work, just friends.
男嘉宾:普通朋友
Male Guest: Just friends.
Katrina: 大家一起唱就没事
Katrina: If everyone sings together, it's fine.
Katrina: 来来来
Katrina: Come on, come on.
Katrina: RNB是非常适合这种氛围的
Katrina: R&B is perfect for this kind of atmosphere.
Katrina: 没关系挺可爱
Katrina: No worries, it's cute.
Katrina: 没事
Katrina: It's okay.
Shure的女友:都很喜欢
Shure's GF: Everyone likes it.
Jack: 给给给找个词呗
Jack: Give, give, give me some lyrics.
男嘉宾:哦
Male Guest: Oh.
Shure: 发完了记得删
Shure: Remember to delete it after you post.
Shure: 别被你女朋友发现了
Shure: Don't let your girlfriend find out.
Shure: 你不是孤优从立
Shure: You don't stand alone.
Jake:把手扳了
Jake: Twist the hand.
Shure: 很好
Shure: Very good.
Shure: 加入了最后一句
Shure: Added the last line.
Shure: 具有个人特色的rap部分
Shure: With a personal touch in the rap part.
Shure: 这谢彬竹每次最后一下叮一下就是哎
Shure: Bin Zhu always adds a final touch, like, hey.
Shure: 非点睛一下
Shure: It really completes it.
Shure: 就是除了内我基本没听清哈哈哈
Shure: Except for that, I basically didn't hear anything, haha.
Nicous: 两条进不去啊没歌词
Nicous: Two lines can't fit, no lyrics.
Shure: 嗯
Shure: Hmm.
Shure: 好该谁了
Shure: Okay, whose turn is it?
Shure: 到谁了
Shure: Who's next?
Katrina: 会弹的不就你们两个吗
Katrina: Aren't you two the only ones who can play?
男嘉宾:对呀
Male Guest: Yeah.
Katrina: 点歌呗
Katrina: Pick a song then.
Shure: 主要我我唱的
Shure: Mainly, I'll be singing.
Shure: 对
Shure: Yeah.
Katrina: 你点个呗
Katrina: You pick one.
Shure: 好别摘不下来
Shure: Okay, don't take it off.
Shure: 对
Shure: Yeah.
Katrina: 嗯
Katrina: Hmm.
Shure: 这个这个呢
Shure: How about this one?
男嘉宾:好摘
Male Guest: Easy to take off.
Shure: 那如果摘不下来呢
Shure: What if it doesn't come off?
男嘉宾:好摘
Male Guest: Easy to take off.
Shure: 哦只要不丢就行
Shure: Oh, as long as it doesn't get lost.
Shure: 但是手指手指可以去是吧
Shure: But fingers can go, right?
Nicous: 这什么
Nicous: What's this?
Shure: 淘汰
Shure: Eliminate.
Katrina: 前面怎么唱来着
Katrina: How does the beginning go?
Shure: 这也不能顶
Shure: This can't be topped.
Shure: 那我那我先摘一个
Shure: Then I'll take one off first.
Shure: 摘不下来的时候
Shure: When it doesn't come off.
Shure的女友:哎呀别别别别别
Sister Shure: Oh no, don't, don't, don't.
Shure: 到时候跟我妈妈哭
Shure: Then I'll cry to my mom.
Shure: 妈妈你看
Shure: Mom, look.
Shure: 他把我这个戒指抢走还摘不下来
Shure: He took my ring and it won't come off.
Shure: 妈给他剁了哈
Shure: Mom, chop it off for him.
Shure的女友:我知道不能丢
Sister Shure: I know it can't get lost.
Shure: 好好好
Shure: Okay, okay.
Shure的女友:这个丢了我真哭给你看
Sister Shure: If it gets lost, I'll really cry for you.
Shure: 我知道我知道
Shure: I know, I know.
Katrina: 受不了了
Katrina: Can't take it anymore.
Katrina: 这对小情侣
Katrina: This couple.
Katrina: 我怎么看不清词啊
Katrina: Why can't I see the lyrics clearly?
Shure: 几天怎么这么爱我
Shure: Why do you love me so much these days?
Shure: 多爽啊
Shure: It's so cool.
Shure: 还每天能拿300块
Shure: And I can get 300 bucks every day.
Shure的女友:没有其实每个周末跟你出去玩的话
Sister Shure: Actually, every weekend if we go out together.
Katrina: 直接拍情侣写真了
Katrina: Just take couple photos directly.
Shure的女友:会是在正常生活中
Sister: It could be in normal life.
Jake:草 这他妈怎么起来
Jake: Damn, how the hell did this happen?
Shure的女友:然后出现一点很失去的情况
Sister: Then there are some really lost moments.
Shure的女友:但是特别好
Sister: But it's really good.
Shure的女友:只要我正常生活也没有什么很好的
Sister: As long as I live normally, there's nothing much really good.
Alice:是的
Alice: Yes.
Katrina: 哎  哎哟什么时候我也有男朋友
Katrina: Hey, when will I have a boyfriend too?
Shure: 无妨
Shure: It doesn't matter.
Katrina: 拍一个哈哈哈
Katrina: Take a picture, haha.
Lucia:前面那些歌我都没听过
Lucia: I haven't heard those songs before.
Alice:你应该不怎么听中文歌吧
Alice: You probably don't listen to Chinese songs much, right?
Lucia:我听得比较少
Lucia: I don't listen to them much.
Lucia:因为我有几个很喜欢的歌手
Lucia: Because there are a few singers I really like.
Shure的女友:就你知道他们在那找吗
Sister: Do you know where they are looking?
Lucia:然后听他们听的比较多
Lucia: So, I listen to them a lot.
Shure的女友:我上回跟Darry和顾老师
Sister: Last time, I went singing with Darry and Teacher Gu.
Lucia:所以留下的听别的歌的时间就很少
Lucia: So, there's little time left to listen to other songs.
Shure的女友:两个人去唱歌玩
Sister: You know that day too.
Shure的女友:那天你也知道
Sister: We went to sing and have fun.
Jake:走道没了
Jake: The path is gone.
Shure的女友:然后就是我说陈奕迅OK这首
Sister: Then I said, Eason Chan, okay, this song.
Shure的女友:然后他们跟我说
Sister: Then they told me.
Alice:有点困了
Alice: I'm a bit sleepy.
Katrina: 哈哈
Katrina: Haha.
Shure的女友:就是我找那种
Sister: I'm looking for those.
Lucia:发现无法融入歌单
Lucia: Finding it hard to fit into the playlist.
Shure的女友:我感觉大家都会唱的歌
Sister: I feel like everyone knows how to sing.
Lucia:变得I了起来
Lucia: It became awkward.
Shure的女友:他说OK这一首我好像知道
Sister: He said, okay, this one I might know.
Alice:没事你本来就I 无所谓
Alice: It's fine, you're always awkward, no worries.
Shure的女友:但是我不会唱
Sister: But I can't sing it.
Katrina: 周杰伦还有什么歌
Katrina: What other songs does Jay Chou have?
Shure的女友:然后你在说什么
Sister: Then what are you talking about?
Shure的女友:那你为什么要找粤语歌
Sister: Why are you looking for Cantonese songs?
Shure的女友:你找粤语歌
Sister: You're looking for Cantonese songs.
Shure的女友:你不找伊森的歌
Sister: You're not looking for Ethan's songs.
Shure的女友:什么东西
Sister: What is this?
Shure的女友:最后唱的什么
Sister: What was the last song?
Shure的女友:就是反正大家会唱粤语歌
Sister: Anyway, everyone can sing Cantonese songs.
Shure的女友:但是唱的什么我也不知道
Sister: But I don't know what they were singing.
Shure的女友:忘记了忘记了
Shure's GF: Forgot, forgot.
Shure: 东北人有自己的一套粤语体系
Shure: Northeastern people have their own Cantonese system.
Shure: 知道吗哈哈哈哈
Shure: Did you know? Hahaha.
Shure的女友:不是啊戴瑞家山西的啊
Shure's GF: No, Dairui is from Shanxi.
Alice:他没带走
Alice: He didn't take it away.
Lucia:好可爱
女嘉宾:戴瑞是山西人
Female guest: Dairui is from Shanxi.
Katrina: 这我也听过
Katrina: I've heard that too.
Katrina: 这不是高中的时候
Katrina: Isn't this from high school?
Shure的女友:我忘了山西哪里了
Shure's GF: I forgot which part of Shanxi.
Shure的女友:但反正是山西人
Shure's GF: But definitely from Shanxi.
Lucia:不要拆散我们的小狗cp
Lucia: Don't break up our little puppy couple.
Katrina: 听的诗班淡淡的
Katrina: Listening to the choir, so calming.
Lucia:刚好
Lucia: Just right.
Alice:那狗子CP
Alice: That puppy couple.
Lucia:狗子CP嗯
Lucia: Puppy couple, yeah.
Lucia:好可爱真可爱这花花也做得好好
Lucia: So cute, really cute, and this flower arrangement is so good.
Alice:你可以把这个头拆走
Alice: You can take this head off.
Katrina: 哈哈这首好适合吉他弹
Katrina: Haha, this song is so suitable for guitar.
Lucia:我去找一个你拆
Lucia: I'll find one, you take it apart.
Alice:谢谢
Alice: Thanks.
Lucia:啊 谢谢
Lucia: Ah, thanks.
Katrina: 嗯
Katrina: Hmm.
Alice:没事你喜欢的话你拿走也行
Alice: No problem, if you like it, you can take it.
Shure的女友:啊就是拍卖的开辟
Shure's GF: Ah, it's the auction opening.
Shure的女友:已经不属于他的买家了是吗
Shure's GF: It no longer belongs to his buyer, right?
Jack: 对呀
Jack: Yeah.
Alice:对
Alice: Right.
Lucia:对对
Lucia: Yeah, yeah.
Jack: 啊好过分啊
Jack: Ah, that's so mean.
Alice:哈哈哈
Alice: Hahaha.
Alice:困了有点
Alice: I'm a bit sleepy.
Alice:我真的困了
Alice: I'm really sleepy.
Shure: 自已倒啊
Shure: Pour it yourself.
Shure的女友:气泡水和朗姆其实还可以
Shure's GF: Sparkling water and rum actually go well together.
Shure: 洗发水应该买的
Shure: Should've bought shampoo.
Shure的女友:但我感觉
Shure's GF: But I feel like...
Shure的女友:我感觉它最好
Shure's GF: I feel like it's best...
Shure的女友:其实是伏特加是最好的
Shure's GF: Actually, vodka is the best.
Shure的女友:但是不知道为什么你们没买
Shure's GF: But I don't know why you guys didn't buy it.
Shure: 我有半瓶一直说要带来的
Shure: 一直谁过来的时候都忘了带
Shure的女友:像罗舒兰这种东西
Shure的女友:我觉得他只适合做少婷
但Shure的女友:你买一瓶罗舒兰
Shure的女友:我其实不是很不是很理解
Shure的女友:不是很理解就是这种
他虽然那个入口特别好
Shure的女友:但是他他对我来说只适合做绍兴
Shure的女友:前几年真的挺流行
Shure的女友:真的
Shure的女友:但是但是
Shure的女友:在网易云的那个归类里面
Shure的女友:功德被归到了说唱
Shure的女友:i mean the why
Shure: 因为他有他有关联的
Shure: 比如说像豆芽这种课
Shure的女友:可能all right
Shure: rap是多吧
Shure: 又开始了
Shure: Here we go again.
Shure的女友:对对对
Shure's GF: Yeah, yeah, yeah.
Shure的女友:但他不是他不是
Shure's GF: But he's not, he's not.
Shure的女友:他真的不是
Shure's GF: He really isn't.
Shure的女友:你可以把归到任何一个类
Shure's GF: You can put him in any category.
Shure的女友:就是甚至你把归到华语大流行都行
Shure's GF: Like, you can even put him in Mandarin pop.
Shure的女友:但他真的不是说唱
Shure's GF: But he's really not rap.
Shure的女友:其实你可以把我背到口中
Shure's GF: Actually, you can put me on the spot.
Shure的女友:我也不知道
Shure's GF: I don't even know.
Shure的女友:音乐人的乐园
Shure's GF: It's a musician's paradise.
Shure: 谁知道
Shure: Who knows.
Alice:我看着拉炼我呢
Alice: I'm looking at the zipper.
Lucia:噢
Lucia: Oh.
Alice:我一定看好吗
Alice: I'm definitely looking, okay?
Alice:我一定看啊
Alice: I'm definitely looking.
Alice:结束了吗还是什么
Alice: Is it over, or what?
Alice:这是干嘛
Alice: What's this about?
Alice:什么环节
Alice: What segment is this?
Lucia:无法融入歌单
Lucia: Can't fit into the playlist.
Lucia:大部分都没听过
Lucia: Most of it I've never heard.
Shure: 给你胖了
Shure: You gained weight.
Shure: 你不是怕被踢了
Shure: Aren't you afraid of being kicked out?
Alice:什么刘婷要唱凤凰传奇
Alice: What? Liu Ting wants to sing Phoenix Legend.
Shure的女友:高了高了高了
Shure's GF: Higher, higher, higher.
Lucia:没有谱子
Lucia: There's no sheet music.
Lucia:可是伴奏同学依然会弹
Lucia: But the accompanist still knows how to play.
Jack: 果然这个歌词你不会了
Jack: As expected, you don't know the lyrics.
Alice:后面不会了
Alice: I don't know the rest.
Jack: 找一下词好吗
Jack: Can you find the lyrics?
Shure的女友:啊不这种歌只要记住副歌就行
Shure's GF: Ah no, for this kind of song, just remember the chorus.
Alice:凤凰传奇上
Alice: Phoenix Legend song.
刘婷:我其实也不太会唱
Liu Ting: Actually, I don't really know how to sing it.
Jake:再找一个再找一个
Jake: Find another one, find another one.
Jack: 除了副歌的词一遍也记不住
Jack: Besides the chorus, I can't remember any of the lyrics.
刘婷:主要是上吧
Liu Ting: It's mainly the chorus.
Alice:上吧上吧
Alice: Just do it, just do it.
刘婷:图个氛围
Liu Ting: It's just for the atmosphere.
刘婷:不是我会
Liu Ting: It's not that I know it well.
Shure: 不我们有
Shure: No, we have it.
Shure: 我们有全民k歌这个软件的
Shure: We have that karaoke app, you know?
Shure: 你知道吗
Shure: You know?
Jack: 分分钟需要你
Jack: "Need You Every Minute".
男嘉宾:都不太会唱
Male Guest: No one really knows how to sing it.
Shure的女友:啊不刚刚他就在啊
Shure's GF: Ah no, he was just here.
Shure的女友:刚刚还跟我说说为什么不能唱那个啊
Shure's GF: He just told me why he couldn't sing that.
Shure: 啊
Shure: Ah.
Shure的女友:就是就是就是
Shure's GF: Exactly, exactly, exactly.
Shure: 我们有有有
Shure: We have, we have, we have.
Shure: 全民k歌的
Shure: The karaoke app.
Jack: 为什么没有唱吧之类的
Jack: Why don't we have something like "Sing Bar"?
Shure: 来来来我们是有的
Shure: Come on, we do.
Shure: 大家
Shure: Everyone.
Jack: 吉他这边就自个看
Jack: Look at the guitar part yourself.
Jack: 然后我们另外一个手机
Jack: And then our other phone.
Jack: 放在KTV的那个
Jack: Put it at the KTV.
男嘉宾:对对对来吧
Male Guest: Yeah, yeah, let's go.
Shure: 来吧
Shure: Let's go.
Shure: 我们其实早就为了这个k歌程序的啊
Shure: Actually, we've been preparing for this karaoke program for a while.
Shure: 什么
Shure: What?
男嘉宾:婧康真的不要高歌一曲
Male Guest: Jing Kang, don't you want to sing a song?
男嘉宾:这可是我们宝贵的数据资源车呀
Male Guest: This is our precious data resource vehicle.
男嘉宾:468861哦你摄影他就要拍了
Male Guest: 468861, oh you film, he'll start shooting.
男嘉宾:然后就不会说两个一起的
Male Guest: Then they won't say two at the same time.
男嘉宾:也有道理啊
Male Guest: That makes sense.
Tasha:把电脑拿给我呗
Tasha: Hand me the computer.
Shure: 唉好
Shure: Alright.
Tasha:还有 对
Tasha: And, yes.
Tasha:搞不完了快
Tasha: Can't finish it, hurry up.
Shure的女友:你可以就是
Shure: You can just...
Alice:写完
Alice: Finish writing.
男嘉宾:陈奕迅的粤语歌词
Male Guest: Eason Chan's Cantonese lyrics.
男嘉宾:我的粤语都是来吧
Male Guest: My Cantonese is all from there.
Shure: 来吧咱们
Shure: Come on, let's...
Tasha:多少次 一万七千多
Tasha: How many times? Over seventeen thousand.
Jake:我去
Jake: Oh my.
Tasha:唉
Tasha: Ugh.
Jake:没关系没关系
Jake: It's okay, it's okay.
Jake:噢
Jake: Oh.
Jake:检查工作
Jake: Check the work.
Jake:例行检查
Jake: Routine check.
Shure: 为什么这首歌
Shure: Why this song?
Jake:没有没有
Jake: No, no.
Jake:就就例行检查这个灯亮不亮
Jake: Just a routine check, to see if the light works.
Jake:就吃水果是一个好表现
Jake: Eating fruit is a good performance.
Jake:但是灯不亮就不行
Jake: But if the light doesn't work, that's not good.
Jake:对对对就就水果就白吃了
Jake: Yeah, yeah, then the fruit is wasted.
Jake:就还得再吃一遍
Jake: You have to eat it again.
Lucia:你吓得我水果都不知道放哪了
Lucia: You scared me so much, I don't know where to put the fruit.
Katrina: 我觉得
Katrina: I think...
Jake:找线呢
Jake: Looking for the wire.
Jake:你出去找找
Jake: Go outside and look for it.
Tasha:说什么来着
Tasha: What did you say?
Jake:放哪去了
Jake: Where did it go?
Katrina: 领导有个坏场所不知道他为什么
Katrina: The leader has a bad venue, don't know why.
Shure: 这首好像伴伴奏有点小
Shure: This song's accompaniment seems a bit low.
Jake:噢
Jake: Oh.
Jake:好吧那关了再开
Jake: Alright, then turn it off and on again.
Jake:哎呀
Jake: Oh dear.
Lucia:啊他现在变成charging了
Lucia: Ah, now it's charging.
Lucia:嗯好吧
Lucia: Hmm, okay.
Lucia:那刚不知为什么断了对
Lucia: It just cut off suddenly, right?
Jake:对 只要他是亮的就行
Jake: Yeah, as long as it's on, it's fine.
Lucia:用户体验
Lucia: User experience.
Jake:是
Jake: Yes.
Jake:用户还有一天可以体验
Jake: Users can still experience it for a day.
Lucia: ok
Lucia: Okay.
Tasha:哎
Tasha: Hey.
Jake:好的
Jake: Alright.
Lucia:进行一些压力测试
Lucia: Let's do some stress testing.
Jake:用户好好体验一下
Jake: Let the users have a good experience.
Jake:是的是的
Jake: Yes, yes.
Jake:这些都是问题
Jake: These are all issues.
Jake:刚刚为什么没有录
Jake: Why didn't it record just now?
Lucia:我不知道 我也很奇怪
Lucia: I don't know. I'm puzzled too.
Jake:因为对
Jake: Because, yeah.
Jake:是就是就是
Jake: Yes, exactly.
Jake:QA我们的数据里面会有一些问题
Jake: There might be some issues in our QA data.
Jake:刚刚为什么没有
Jake: Why didn't it...
Jake:然后就可以回答
Jake: Then we can answer.
Jake:因为用户体验不行
Jake: Because the user experience is bad.
Jake:这是什么
Jake: What is this?
Tasha:嗯
Tasha: Hmm.
Jake:这是什么
Jake: What is this?
Tasha:这是
Tasha: This is...
Tasha:唉 我明天要答辩了
Tasha: Ugh, I have a defense tomorrow.
Jake:我要答辩了
Jake:你要来工作
Jake: Are you coming to work?
Jake:外头吧没拿回来唉应该楼上楼上他们
Jake: Outside? They probably took it upstairs.
Jake:哈哈哈差不多
Jake: Haha, almost.
Jake:在楼上
Jake: Upstairs.
Jake:线找了吗 在哪里
Jake: Did you find the cable? Where is it?
Jake:完了 眼镜掉了
Jake: Oh no, my glasses fell.
Jake:谢谢 谢谢
Jake: Thanks, thanks.
Jake:再拧一个
Jake: Twist another one.
Lucia:椰乳再拿一个是吧
Lucia: Another coconut milk, right?
Jake:嗯
Jake: Yeah.
Alice:哎小心小心
Alice: Hey, careful, careful.
Jake:没关系 楼下再开一桌
Jake: It's okay, we'll set up another table downstairs.
Lucia:都退场了
Lucia: Everyone has left.
Jake:不对
Jake: No, that's not right.
Jake:东北分会场
Jake: The Northeast branch.
Alice:最近感觉超上火
Alice: Lately, I've been feeling really stressed.
Alice:想洗脸了
Alice: I want to wash my face.
刘婷:去吧
Liu Ting: Go ahead.
Alice:真嘟吗
Alice: Really?
刘婷:老了到点困了有点
Liu Ting: Getting old, feeling sleepy at this time.
Alice:真的吗
Alice: Really?
刘婷:你不你不你不卸妆吗
Liu Ting: Aren't you going to remove your makeup?
Alice:卸等会卸
Alice: I'll remove it later.
Alice:洗 等我一下
Alice: Wash, wait for me.
Alice:看还有多少
Alice: Let's see how much is left.
Jake:那是找对地方了
Jake: Then you're in the right place.
Lucia:都可以吃吧
Lucia: Can we eat it all?
Jake:哈哈当然不是的干嘛
Jake: Haha, of course not, why would you?
Lucia:请示一下领导
Lucia: Let me check with the boss.
Jake:不吃这些东西呢
Jake: We don't eat this stuff.
Jake:怎么处理呢
Jake: How do we handle it?
Alice:今天几点下班
Alice: What time do we get off work today?
Shure的女友:就是他真的只适合入手
Shure's GF: He's really only suitable for starters.
Jake:好问题我也不知道
Jake: Good question, I don't know either.
Shure的女友:虽然他入口性很很好但是
Shure's GF: Although he has a great taste, but...
Alice:困了
Alice: I'm sleepy.
Jake:对
Jake: Right.
Lucia:领导都 不知道几点下班
Lucia: Even the boss doesn't know what time we get off work.
Alice:领导这个不知道有点
Alice: It's kind of nice that the boss doesn't know this.
Alice:还蛮好的
Alice: It's pretty good.
Jake:那 咱
Jake: So, we...
Jake:咱
Jake: We...
Alice:好的
Alice: Okay.
Jake:咱是咱是
Jake: We are, we are...
Jake:算什么点
Jake: What time is it?
Jake:十一 十一  十一十一六 十一十一七
Jake: Eleven, eleven, eleven sixteen, eleven seventeen.
Alice:十一十一7
Alice: Eleven seventeen.
Jake:十一十一7
Jake: Eleven seventeen.
Jake:哈哈 确实 太博学了
Jake: Haha, indeed, very knowledgeable.
Jake:这个
Jake: This...
Jake:是是是我错了我错了
Jake: Yes, yes, it's my fault, my fault.
Jake:这每天十一十一七的玩
Jake: Every day at eleven seventeen.
Jake:高强度玩耍
Jake: Intense playtime.
Alice:哈哈哈
Alice: Hahaha
Alice:11点结束之后还得网购买东西
Alice: After it ends at 11, I still have to do some online shopping.
Lucia:不要太离谱
Lucia: Don't go overboard.
Jake:太高强度了
Jake: It's too intense.
Alice:算加班
Alice: Consider it overtime.
Jake:还加班还加班还加班
Jake: Overtime, overtime, overtime.
Lucia:对还要加班
Lucia: Yeah, still overtime.
Jake:店还没开
Jake: The store isn't even open yet.
Jake:好嘞好嘞
Jake: Alright, alright.
Alice:闯入人家闺房干什么啊
Alice: Why are you barging into her room?
刘婷:你不许进来
Liu Ting: You're not allowed in here.
Shure的女友:还有
Shure's GF: And...
Jake:只是他不许进来哈哈哈哈哈
Jake: Only he is not allowed in, hahaha.
Alice:倒返天罡了
Alice: It's like reversing the heavens.
Alice:倒返天罡了这
Shure: 啊我们还有一个香槟没开呢
Shure: Ah, we still have a bottle of champagne unopened.
Lucia:开始录8%居然就可以了
Lucia: Starting to record at 8% is actually fine.
Shure: 有有
Shure: Yeah, yeah.
Jake:对 5%以上应该是
Jake: Right, anything above 5% should be.
Shure的女友:有
Shure's GF: Yes.
Shure: 他不是香槟
Shure: It's not champagne.
Shure: 就是一个气泡酒
Shure: It's just sparkling wine.
Lucia:哎不愧是领导
Lucia: Wow, as expected from a leader.
Alice:哎这眼镜感觉损耗了
Alice: Oh, these glasses feel worn out.
Alice:就是这几天发现充着电还是耗电
Alice: It's like even when charging, it's still draining.
Jake:没关系损
Jake: No worries, wear them out.
Jake:使劲损
Jake: Wear them out as much as you can.
Lucia:对刚开始我觉得差
Lucia: Yeah, at first, I thought they were bad.
Alice:尊嘟 真
Alice: Really, really.
Jake:随便损
Jake: Wear them out freely.
Alice:真的吗
Alice: Really?
Alice:这个如果用坏了不还要买新的吗
Alice: If they break, we have to buy new ones, right?
Lucia:没事这捐给他们了
Lucia: It's okay, we donated them.
Lucia:哦
Lucia: Oh.
Jake:咱们咱项目要不
Jake: Our project, shall we...
Jack: 老板不差钱
Jack: The boss isn't short on money.
Jake:主要是捐的
Jake: Mainly it's donated.
Jake:就主要是这批货只要不用坏就能用
Jake: As long as we don't break this batch, we can use them.
Jake:咱下一批就下一批
Jake: The next batch is the next batch.
Alice:等于说你想用新的呗
Alice: So you actually want to use new ones.
Jake:也不是也不是
Jake: Not exactly, not exactly.
Alice:这是可以录的吗
Alice: Can this be recorded?
Jack: 已经录下了
Jack: It's already been recorded.
Lucia:咦确实就算我们眼镜没开过户也开了
Lucia: Oh yeah, even if we haven't opened an account with the glasses, it's still on.
Alice:就是一直通着电之后还是一个那啥
Alice: It's still on even after being connected for a while.
Shure: 楼上开还是楼下开啊
Shure: Upstairs or downstairs?
Jake:噢
Jake: Oh.
Lucia:对他还是会断我觉得
Lucia: Yeah, it still gets cut off, I think.
Lucia:前两天没这样
Lucia: It wasn't like this a couple days ago.
Shure: 楼下吧这设备太多了
Shure: Probably downstairs, there are too many devices.
Alice:一边进水一边放水还是放的快
Alice: Water goes in one side and out the other, but it drains faster.
Lucia:什么小学数学题
Lucia: What kind of elementary math problem is this?
Jack: 没事 漏得快没关系
Jack: It's fine, it leaks fast, no problem.
Alice:小学数学题
Alice: Elementary math problem.
Jake:挺好挺好
Jake: Very good, very good.
Jake:就把它就是
Jake: Just make it...
Jake:最大的价值是吧 剥削掉
Jake: Extract the maximum value from it, right?
Jake:我们剥削眼镜最大的价值
Jake: We exploit the maximum value of the glasses.
Lucia:你这是给眼镜配了个劳动力吧
Lucia: You're giving the glasses some labor, aren't you?
Lucia:入职的时候公司给配发那个
Lucia: The company provided that when you joined.
Lucia:叫什么麦克
Lucia: What's it called, Mike?
Jake:哦
Jake: Oh.
Lucia:给麦克配了个劳动力
Lucia: Gave Mike some labor.